[Musica]
il futuro appartiene a coloro che
credono nei propri sogni
una frase bellissima straordinaria è
particolarmente importante esattamente
nel momento in cui ci troviamo a porci
delle domande importanti nella vita come
ad esempio cosa farò da grande una
domanda che sicuramente ci saremmo fatti
tutti e si farà in questo momento in
particolar modo la next generation ed è
una domanda che per qualche motivo crea
sempre tensione agitazione a volte
insonnia molto spesso una domanda che fa
paura d'altronde come non avere paura di
fronte a un milione arrabbiato come
questo evidentemente di fronte a una
situazione nuova come quella che vedete
nella foto ci si può porre in diversi
modi e da come ci poniamo alle
nell'affrontare le situazioni cambia la
situazione ad esempio è chiaro che non
immagino nessuno penserebbe mai di porsi
davanti una situazione del genere come
questo bambino spavaldo yeah
tranquillissimo come se niente fosse
molto più facile che ci si rivolga a
quella situazione in questo modo io
quantomeno mi riconosco in questo
bambino spaventato ma cos'è la paura in
realtà molto spesso noi erroneamente
associamo la paura alla vigliaccheria
non è così la paura in realtà è
un'emozione un sentimento
importantissimo che ci porta a fare
attenzione ea dare il massimo in quel
momento in cui ci troviamo in una
situazione imprevista quindi la paura a
volte ti può anche salvare la vita
quindi di cosa parliamo di momenti
importanti nei quali dobbiamo fare delle
scelte e questa paura questa incertezza
questa situazione ce lo troviamo
esattamente quando dobbiamo scegliere o
pensare a cosa farò da grande ma se ci
pensate è una cosa molto semplice c'è un
bivio davanti a noi dove scegliamo o la
via del futuro che come vedete in questo
caso è bloccata dalla presenza della
tigre che rappresenta se vogliamo
l'ostacolo da superare
oppure
vi è molto facile a destra è in discesa
che ti dice vieni e quindi ti invita a
prendere a fare quella scelta
beh io devo ammettere in qualche caso da
ragazzino sono stato attratto dallo
scegliere la via più facile ma ogni
volta in cui io sceglievo la via più
facile mi rimaneva dentro un senso di
vuoto qualche un senso di disagio non
ero contento di me e in particolar modo
mi tornava in mente sempre delle frasi
se avessi detto se avessi fatto se
avessi avuto il coraggio quindi in
qualche modo non ero felice di me stesso
bene può capitare spesso di prendere la
strada sbagliata ma è anche importante
saper tornare indietro quindi io in
qualche modo sono tornato indietro e ho
deciso di affrontare le mie paure come
penso più o meno avrà fatto ognuno di
noi nei diversi ambiti della vita e in
diversi momenti importanti della vita
ma di cosa abbiamo bisogno in questo
momento in quel momento qual è il più
importante ingrediente beh potremmo
vista la situazione avrei bisogno o di
un fucile o di una spada oppure
decidiamo di affrontare a brevi mani la
tigre a dire fatti sotto vedete in
realtà è un aspetto molto importante
la cosa più importante ed invisibile di
cui in realtà abbiamo bisogno in quel
momento invece bisogno di un sogno
dobbiamo sognare sognare è un elemento è
un qualcosa che ci porta ad avere una
visione diversa sognare ci fa volare in
alto e non credete a quelli che vi
dicono che sognare ti porta in alto e
poi cadi ti fai più male non è così
sognare tipo sta in alto ti porta a
vedere le cose esattamente per quello
che sono
ti da quella vista così chiaro e così
pulita che pensate quella tigre
molto probabilmente scoprirete era un
vicino mia non era una tiga quindi il
nostro punto di vista che cambia in base
alla situazione per cui più tardi amo ad
affrontare quella situazione più il
micino diventa una tigre quanto prima
l'affrontiamo più facilmente ci
accorgeremo che era un vicino però
qualcuno potrebbe anche dire e se quel
vicino invece dovesse essere davvero una
tigre
beh allora l'affrontiamo non credo che
sia la prima volta in cui capita un
imprevisto una situazione difficile non
credo che ci sia nessuno al mondo che
abbia realizzato qualcosa di importante
o di straordinario o abbia realizzato il
suo sogno senza fatica senza difficoltà
senza affrontare dei problemi
questo è un imprevisto e noi lo
affrontiamo quella tigre in realtà
rappresenta i limiti che qualcuno ci
involontariamente ci impone oi limiti
che ci poniamo noi oppure la nostra
emozione dopo una sconfitta la sconfitta
però non deve buttarci giù la sconfitta
è importantissima nella vita perché ci
dà un segnale importante su quale
aspetto noi dobbiamo lavorare se decido
che voglio diventare il campione del
mondo dei 100 metri pronti partenza via
vado
evidentemente siamo destinati già una
sconfitta perché mi accorgerò che
campione del mondo ci ha impiegato poco
più di 9 secondi e io ci impiego 13
quindi devo allenarmi lavorare se prendo
una sconfitta quello è un messaggio che
ho bisogno di allenarmi e quindi non è
un qualcosa che deve abbattere il nostro
stato d'animo ed in particolar modo
sappiate che sognare e credere nei
propri sogni
e un qualcosa di straordinario di magico
vi fa quasi sentire dei supereroi
e ci fa avere dei poteri straordinari
come wonder woman è come superman
in realtà non è così facile ma in realtà
c'è da dire una cosa quando io credo nel
mio sogno
io acquisisco dei superpoteri perché io
raggiungo il mio sogno se ci credo
davvero
vedete c'è un solo aspetto importante
del quale tener conto tener conto in
particolar modo dipende sempre e solo da
noi non c'è nessun altro che può
realizzare il nostro sogno al nostro
posto
ma non c'è nessuno che deve rompere il
nostro sogno che deve buttare giù il
nostro sogno quindi dipende sempre e
solo da noi
molto spesso può capitare
e se quella persona mi avesse aiutato se
quella persona non avesse fatto questo
scuse dipende sempre e solo da noi
pensate c'è un detto che dice da cosa
nasce cosa
è vero ma le cose non accadano mai per
caso le cose accadono perché le facciamo
accadere noi le cose accadono perché le
facciamo accadere noi perché ci crediamo
c'è una cosa incredibile che accade nel
momento in cui noi sogniamo
ed è questa la forza incredibile della
nostra mente
io sogno ciò che voglio essere da grande
io sogno il fatto di sognare mi porta
immediatamente michele trasporta in quel
futuro che io devo inseguire sognare
trasforma la nostra mente in una potente
calamita già però quella calamità come
vedete in questo momento non è
attiva non ha capacità di attrattiva
perché non basta sognare basse dimetto
li voglio una ferrari taha che la
ferrari subito in garage non è così
sognare è l'aspetto più importante
ma nel sognare per rendere possibile la
realizzazione di quel sogno ho bisogno
di due aspetti altrettanto importanti
così come sognare ed è tenacia e
determinazione
determinazione perché io voglio
essere quella persona io voglio
diventare un ballerino voglio diventare
una ballerina e allora io con la mia
determinazione continuo tenacia perché
dalla quantità di lavoro e dalla
costanza con cui io mi applicherò nel
realizzare quel mio sogno determinerà
sicuramente il risultato finale quindi
torniamo al discorso che abbiamo detto
poc'anzi dipende sempre e solo da noi
allora in questo modo io avrò come
vedete attivato il magnete inizia la
magia
il sogno si può avverare beh qualcuno di
voi potrà dire
la fai facile io vi sto parlando della
mia vita vi sto parlando della mia
esperienza vi sto parlando di ciò che
accade davvero vi sto parlando del sogno
di quel bambino vi racconterò il mio
sogno che un sogno che credo coinvolga
moltissime persone da piccolo ognuno ha
le sue aspirazioni non c'è chi sogna di
fare l'astronauta che i sogni di fare a
volte
l'aspetto più importante che quando noi
raccontiamo i nostri sogni sembra che
le persone c de rita non deve mai
accadere che questo aspetto
incide negativamente sul nostro sogno
per esempio io adoro i miei genitori pur
sapendo
di avergli sicuramente fatto avere tante
preoccupazioni io da piccolo ad esempio
ero attratto dagli antichi rimedi
erboristici io passavo tanto tempo in sé
in compagnia degli anziani contadini del
luogo dove mi facevo raccontare i vecchi
rimedi erboristici come fare questi
intrugli come applicarli per risolvere
tanti piccoli problemi quotidiani poi
andavo a casa facevo queste piccole
stregona te e da lì poi mi hanno
affibbiato il nomignolo di stregone e
quindi può tornavo da queste persone
dire vedete questo fatto e loro si
entusiasmavano nel vedere questi
risultati ma la cosa più incredibile che
ho cominciato a pensare ea credere che
il mondo avesse un gran bisogno di quei
principi attivi di quelle soluzioni per
migliorare la qualità della vita e lì ho
cominciato a sognare i miei genitori mi
hanno supportato grandemente perché
hanno capito che era il mio sogno
quindi non hanno mai interrotto mai
bloccato questa propensione
non finisce lì un giorno ricordo seconda
media io inizio a sognare ma sarebbe
bello poter fare questo un bambino
qualsiasi ovviamente seconda media
compito in classe il nostro meraviglioso
insegnante di italiano i tempi cc da un
compito
parlaci di cosa vorresti fare da grande
racconta il tuo sogno e io a nozze
subito il fantastico non posso altro che
raccontare questo sogno era io da grande
vorrei avere una fattoria e mi
piacerebbe coltivare le piante
officinali
trasformarle in soluzioni naturali per
migliorare la qualità della vita e
andare in giro per il mondo per vendere
questi prodotti a tutte le persone che
incontro ero convinto che avere preso un
bellissimo voto
e invece no il professore non solo mi ha
messo un brutto voto ma ancor peggio mi
ha deriso davanti a tutta la classe
scrivendomi in rosso ma è bello gr
settato e ci manca una casetta in canada
io mi sono alzato la faccio mi scusi
professore male ci ha chiesto di parlare
di un sogno e basta con questi sogni
dovete avere i piedi per terra
questa la considerazione che ho ricevuto
vi giuro non ho mai permesso a quella
considerazione fuori luogo di
interrompere il mio sogno e e anzi per
me ha funzionato da motivazione
ulteriore perché io ho giurato a me
stesso io a questo signore dove la
spiegargli e fai a far vedere cosa
riuscirò a fare da grande quindi mi ha
motivato e gli sono grato per un certo
verso continuo a sognare da grande
arrivo all'età di 23 anni dopo ho fatto
diversi lavori e mi rendo conto che
questa passione urla e quindi decido di
investire nella mia passione
ecco questo è un altro elemento
importantissimo credo perché se io amo
davvero ciò che faccio nella vita allora
potrò sempre fare la differenza perché
non sarò mai stanco e non sarò mai
affaticato di tutto ciò che faccio e
farò sempre cose straordinarie perché
amo e adoro ciò che faccio ed è quello
che ho rischiato di fare piccolo
laboratorio
iniziò a fare le mie stregona della
mattina fare i miei prodotti naturali
con erbe officinali la serata che giacca
cravatta a vendola fare il
rappresentante di me stesso ma non ero
soddisfatto perché io volevo rompere i
confini andare oltre decido di andare a
milano e ad associarvi all'associazione
di categoria allora si chiamava unipro
l'associazione di cosmesi vado lì bello
giacca cravatta tac tra vivo un giorno
salve prego
racconto la mia idea racconto di un
progetto di creare una filiera
produttiva nel salento per andare dalla
pianta al prodotto cosmetico finito
realizzare una linea dei prodotti di
cosmesi naturale per migliorare la
qualità della vita delle persone nel
mondo questo signore vi fa si fermi
ma lei mi sta parlando di cosmesi
naturale
parliamo dell 88 89
ma lei lo sa che la cosmesi un argomento
chimico come fa a parlare di cosmesi
naturale prima risposta fantastica
e dopodiché mi scusi e da dove viene lei
io vengo da lecce dicevo ecco lei è
troppo a sud
lei è troppo assurdo deve sapere che
tutte le aziende che hanno successo nel
mondo della stella della cosmesi sono a
milano e nell'hinterland di milano
quindi lei deve comprare i contenitori
da milano portare a lecce rifare i
prodotti e rimandarli a milano li è
fuori mercato e troppo a sud
io l'ho ascoltato con attenzione ha
detto mi scusi gli ho fatto vedere una
cartina come questa
per tra scusate
eccola qui
e gli ho detto scusi io vengo da lì mi
spiega meglio il concetto di sud
era un punto di vista evidentemente
perché gli ho detto vede il fatto che io
sono a sud è in realtà ciò che ha
permesso di far nascere il mio sogno
perché il mio sogno è legato al
territorio
il sogno se io fossi nato a londra oa
marghera avrei fatto completamente
qualcosa di diverso questo territorio
con le sue straordinarie ricchezze mi ha
trasmesso questi valori e quindi sogno e
territorio per me diventano la
combinazione vincente di 8 ma lei
conosce il salento
lo sa che il salento è una terra fra due
mari meravigliosa con dei luoghi
straordinari con dei colori bellissimi
con delle paesaggi rurali spettacolari
dove le piante producono dei gusti e dei
colori impressionanti con una storia
incredibile dove esistono ancora degli
antichi mestieri
e questo mi guardava a questo impazzito
e per di più pensate dopo tanti anni è
un po di anni che il nostro salento alla
nostra puglia viene piena premiato come
the best place in the world e io dunque
mi chiedo ma è possibile che debba
arrivare qualcuno dall'america
dall'inghilterra da londra da parigi a
dirci che noi viviamo nel best place in
the world
noi abbiamo qualcosa di straordinario
sotto i nostri piedi ed è bene
cominciare ad enfatizzarne le
opportunità non i limiti il nostro un
territorio che può dare vita a
straordinarie iniziative e della next
generation che deve capire questa
opportunità
voi la vostra capacità straordinaria il
futuro ce l'avete sotto i vostri piedi
potete trasformare ancor di più questo
territorio nel vostro futuro
straordinario vedete e quindi non è come
dire la persona di successo che parla in
questo momento è ancora quel bambino
spaventato perché io ancora mi continuo
a chiedere cosa voglio fare da grande
continua ad avere tanti sogni ma la cosa
più importante che se ce l'ho fatta io
quel bambino spaventato ce la può fare
chiunque ce la potete fare voi ce la
possono fare tutti coloro che vogliono a
patto di ricordarsi di tre aspetti
fondamentali ogni singolo giorno primo
aspetto
sognate
sognate ciò che volete fare da grandi
secondo aspetto importante
affrontate le vostre paure
e terzo aspetto fondamentale credete nel
vostro sogno è fare di tutto per
realizzarlo
a quel punto diventiamo non più
sognatori ma riusciamo a diventare game
changer perché il sognatore e o la
sognatrice e quella persona che sta lì a
sognare basta il game changer è la
persona che fa di tutto per trasformare
quel sogno in una splendida realtà
dunque a quel punto siamo finalmente
pronti per affrontare la partita della
vita ed è un'occasione straordinaria
perché tocca dipende sempre e solo da
noi siamo noi
il giocatore avversario che si potrebbe
chiamare futuro di cosa abbiamo bisogno
in questo caso molto semplice
ecco qui
una pallina ed una bacchetta e
soprattutto prima di iniziare a giocare
se qualcuno mi dice che qualcosa
impossibile non dategli retta sta
parlando dei suoi limiti non dei vostri
enjoy the match
grazie
[Applauso]